she's a
super um
detail oriented obviously as you can see
from a working that's jay-z praising his
wife beyonce telling e.t he finds her
work ethic to
[Music]
be uh incredibly hard worker
super talented
um very inspiring jay and b have been
together for more than 20 years and
married for over a decade
ready
throughout their relationship they have
collaborated frequently with their music
and business ventures most recently the
couple worked together on a new campaign
for tiffany and company in which b wears
a
128.54 carat yellow diamond that dates
back to the 1800s making her the first
black woman ever to wear the piece
et caught up with hole himself at the
18th anniversary of his 40-40 club in
new york city on saturday beyonce was
also in attendance supporting her man
she showed off her look on instagram
which included a bodycon black dress and
some fun hot pink pumps jay-z opened the
first 40-40 club a chain of sports bars
and lounges in new york city in 2003
locations followed in atlanta las vegas
and the barclays center you see a kid
from brooklyn you know so it's big for
us very exciting while speaking with e.t
on the red carpet the hip-hop mogul also
opened up about his new partnership with
fanatics as they moved to open a sports
book in new york making him the only
black investor and one with close ties
to new york it's very important because
you know typically in these things
there's no sort of diversity
there's no one that represents the city
no one from the city
you know so all those things
you know make it a real exciting
opportunity
[Music]
you